before you go let's break down I want to
break down a couple of things
for anybody watching this the things
that they should have in place
whether it's a security blanket in the
bank account whether it's your credit
score needs to be this whether it's you
need to make sure this is in place
before you dip your toe into this real
estate [ __ ] credit is one of the most
important things you always want to make
sure right you got good credit right you
interview a couple different lenders
make sure you're pre-approved right so
you go out there and pull the trigger uh
learn as much as you can when it comes
to the lengthy side of the business
because a lot of times you might get pre
be pre-approved by A lender that is not
looking at everything so make sure you
speak to somebody and interview a couple
different people right contractors same
thing always talk to a couple different
guys like never just go off of it where
oh my cousin recommended to this guy I
grew up with this guy you can't do that
real estate right but credit right
get pre-approved have a couple dollars
gotta have about you would say about 680
to 720 to start
yeah well it depends though because FHA
you can go as low as a 580 credit score
okay but it depends on the market too
right because for us we're a
multi-family land so FHA is great in the
tri-state area but let's say you're in
Cali you don't really have a lot of
multi-families of course so that that's
the thing right because when uh let's
say if you want to buy a three family
right and you only make let's say 40 000
a year which is not a lot of money you
could do it because with FHA they're
gonna use the two other units to help
you qualify for for that property so now
it looks on paper that you make more
money by using the rents so they're
going to use about 75 to 80 of each of
those apartments so if it's a thousand
dollars they're going to use 800 800 add
that to your total income that you make
a year and now you qualify for more but
that's a good hack but you can only do
that with a multi-family it depends
depending on what you have to live in
one of the units yeah you're supposed to
you're supposed to live in one of them I
could say You're supposed to right but
you could always refinance right so a
cool thing just to give the people a
little trick with FHA you could go up to
a four family right so the trick is you
could have up to a four Plex yeah so you
want to start with a four family because
you can only go backwards you can't go
forward so meaning you could go from a
four family refinance go to a three
family refinance go to a two family
refinance and go to one family so each
time you get rid of the FHA but now
you're only putting down three point
five percent so each time you get rid of
the FHA when you refinance you can do
another FHA yep you can do it again and
then once you're done right another hack
once you're done in that area you'll go
to a different state and start over so
each state there it's like a blank slate
on the FHA you can always move nobody
could tell you that you can't move wow
okay and then next thing you know you
know again but start start with four
because in order to use that hack you
can only go backwards yeah but the
problem is it's hard to find four
families they're almost like unicorns so
you'll probably get luckier getting a
three or two gotcha